präsident putin hat mit seinem überfall
auf die ukraine eine neue realität
geschaffen
diese neue realität erfordert eine klare
antwort es ist eine antwort die noch vor
kurzem undenkbar schien
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
härteste finanzsanktionen gegen russland
mehr noch stolz für die bundeswehr
aufrüsten mit einem sondervermögen der
bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten die mittel
werden wir für notwendige investitionen
am sonntag vor einer woche bekommt
kanzler scholz für all das stehen denn
der platz es ist ein ko der scholz aus
der rolle des zauberers an die spitze
der anti putin allianz katapultiert der
führung bestellt bekommt sie bei mir hat
schon mal gesagt in den tagen danach
aber wächst die zahl derer in der ampel
die sich fragen ob sie das was sie nun
bekommen wirklich bestellt haben was
china verlangt ist für viele eine
zumutung aber die viel größeres putins
krieg deshalb öffentlich keine kritik
das kaum jemand eingeweiht war in den
100 milliarden plan
wir haben als ampel eine gute praxis und
die heißt dass wir interne dinge
miteinander besprechen und nicht
übereinander reden und das ist wichtig
für eine erfolgreiche koalition und
daran halten wir uns doch die fürchte
ist groß dass von den ursprünglichen
ampel plänen in kriegszeiten wenig übrig
bleibt ihr versprechen mehr fortschritte
wagen hatte viele kapitel das zur
sicherheitspolitik aber kam erst weit
hinten schien nicht so wichtig jetzt
überragt die frage nach krieg und
frieden alles andere was bleibt ist die
hoffnung des urlaubs scholz der fraktion
zugesichert hat dass neben diesem
sondervermögen natürlich weiter an den
prioritären aufgaben des
koalitionsvertrages gearbeitet wird was
den klimaschutz betrifft was den umbau
der arbeits des wirtschaftens aber auch
wohnen und öffentlicher
personennahverkehr alles das wird
erhalten bleiben
es ist nicht das erste mal dass krieg
eine kollektion zu etwas zwingt auf dass
sie nicht vorbereitet war
1999 rot-grün beteiligt sich im rahmen
der nato im kosovo krieg um weitere
serbische massaker zu verhindern es ist
der erste kampfeinsatz deutscher
soldaten seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
und er hätte die grünen damals fast
zerrissen
und heute die situation ist überhaupt
nicht vergleichbar erstens weil wir
damals sehr frisch mit der verantwortung
betraut wurden heute sind wir in zehn
bundesländern in der regierung und es
ist nichts erste mal dass wir regieren
und außerdem ist auch das niveau der
aggression einfach ein ganz anderes wir
reden nicht über ein kosovo wir reden
über eine atommacht direkt an unserer
grenze genau das wie mit der atommacht
russland umgehen war eine frage die
anfang der 80er jahre die spd spaltete
300.000 demonstrierten in bonn gegen den
nato doppelbeschluss
kanzler helmut schmidt der für
verhandlungen und abschreckung eintrat
wird die zunehmend isoliert
die tradition der friedensbewegung die
abneigung gegen abschreckung das spielt
auch heute eine rolle
das was jetzt eine zeitenwende ist ist
in der tat von präsident putin zu
verantworten dass wir die letzten 20
jahre aber auch erleben mussten das
einseitig rüstungsverträge
abrüstungsverträge gekündigt wurden dass
es keine vertrauensbildung mehr gegeben
hat das ist ja auch klare realität und
da müssen wir auch konsequenzen
ausziehen bei spd und grünen gibt es nun
forderungen das schutzpaket dem
parlament zu verändern welche und
rüstungen dann mit sie wieder
krisenprävention und die klimawende
bekommt ein zusatz argument putin wir
müssen schnellstmöglich von russischen
gas kohle und öl unabhängig wären dafür
braucht es milliarden investitionen
dafür darf die schuldenbremse nicht im
weg stehen dafür dürfen auch die
versprechen beispielsweise keine steuern
für reiche oder vermögende zu erhöhen
nicht weiter im weg stehen und dieses
geld muss jetzt der staat liefern und
dafür muss auch christian lindner
endlich antworten liefern tatsächlich
hat die fdp die geringsten
schwierigkeiten mit dem 100 milliarden
kufen scholz zu lang ist ein
sondervermögen ist solange die
schuldenbremse bleibt aber bleibt also
zunächst mal ist ja so dass wir dieses
sondervermögen beten um den kernhaushalt
gerade nicht zu belasten das gehört zur
sparsame haushaltsführung dazu wir sehen
gerade das alle möglichen parteien ihre
bislang vertretenen position neu
bestimmen müssen das tun wir als spd
ganz offensichtlich gerade wenn es um
militärausgaben wenn es um
waffenlieferungen geht dann kann man
auch von anderen parteien erwarten dass
sie mit ihren heiligen kühen anders
umgehen als in den vergangenen jahren
putins krieg zwingt der ampel
entscheidungen auf die ihrem selbstbild
ihrer dna entgegenstehen die frage ist
nur wie lange wird die koalition dabei
kanzler scholz der regierung umstandslos
folgen
[Musik]